we need to get people back to work we
can't just slip a switch workers want
higher wages as the us recovery pushes
forward there's a rising tension in the
economy and its roots are as old as
business itself
today as jobs go unfilled and wages rise
it's got people talking about one thing
labor shortages labor shortages
labor shortages the whole idea of a
labor shortage is a tricky one as the
fed has pointed out there isn't even one
clear definition of what it means much
less how to measure it
that might be one reason why it's become
such a controversial topic with people
on all sides of the economic spectrum
taking a stance on how much damage it's
doing
what's causing it or whether it's even
real the idea itself comes partly from
business owners who say they're
struggling to fill
open jobs that concern has been around
for a long time
since well before the pandemic even
started and research shows that reports
of labor shortages tend to pick up
whenever there's a recovery
but there's a deeper question about the
economy and it centers on two
key data points one is u.s employment
the total number of americans who
currently have
jobs employment plunged during the
pandemic and then
surged back but it's still about 7
million below where it was just over a
year ago the other number is
job openings which are now at record
highs in the u.s
more than 9 million according to the
labor department so with all these
companies looking for new employees it
begs the question
why aren't people going back to work
this is the part where
some people like to start pointing
fingers the government is paying people
to stay
home they're staying home because
they're getting paid to the problems
that are created here
are self-induced hey we respond to
incentive the truth is we don't have
much evidence that
unemployment benefits are the main thing
keeping jobs from getting filled for one
we didn't see a major pickup in july and
august last year when the federal
government's extra 600
unemployment benefits got cut and then
replaced by a much smaller amount
we also haven't seen a big rush to fill
jobs in the states that got rid of
federal benefits early
and recently the biggest jobs gains have
come from the lowest wage groups
the ones that would stand to see the
highest relative benefits from not
working
and collecting unemployment most
economists do think that money from the
federal government
is one factor that could be adding to
strains in the labor market
but they also point to lingering
coronavirus concerns a lack of child
care options
people wanting to retire early and a
mismatch between open jobs and worker
skills
there is even evidence that the pandemic
has led to a turning point for some
workers
inspiring them to completely rethink
their careers but economists also
believe
there's something else something even
simpler that's keeping people from
coming back into the workforce maybe the
pay just hasn't been good enough
it's an idea that a lot of big
businesses are starting to catch on to
raising wages works most of the time
amazon mcdonald's chipotle and the
wrestling
they're raising wages and the question
is how much do they have to raise wages
raising wages or at least raising
benefits they're going to have to get
the bodies in
to make the places go leading up to the
pandemic wages have been stagnant in the
u.s for decades with workers taking an
ever smaller piece of the economic pie
just pay them more
sounds like an easy solution but some
businesses can't afford it
and there's concern that higher pay
could lead to lasting inflation
if companies raise prices to pay those
higher wages
so far wage gains haven't been out of
control and they've been
concentrated among lower income groups
rather than high earners
president biden has said that's not such
a bad thing
when it comes to the economy we're
building rising wages
aren't a bug they're a feature as the
recovery continues
so does the debate over what's best for
the economy and
while a tighter labor market might be
putting pressure on some businesses
it could also be granting an opportunity
to labor itself
one that gives workers a chance to come
out ahead of where they started
[Music]